l'équitation est un sport d'extérieur à
cheval c'est s'ils empruntent
régulièrement chemins privés ou
communaux alors quand elle entend parler
d'une pétition pour un dimanche sans
chasse heures elle n'hésite pas à signer
on subit de plus en plus en fait la
réticence à aller en extérieur pendant
quasiment dix mois de l'année puisque
les périodes de chasse ont été rallongés
pour certains gibiers
ce serait presque un prudent et je veux
dire d'aller dans les forêts d'aller
dans des chemins d'aller près des
parcelles de maïs comme à cette époque
qui sont très hautes où on est mal vu et
ce serait même inconscient d'y emmener
des élèves une inquiétudes liées au
passé il y a dix huit ans dans la vallée
de chevreuse cécile frôlé la mort à
cause d'un chasseur c'était un dimanche
elle montait à cheval accompagné d'un
élève une balle a été tirée on l'a
entendu très fortement
et le pire c'est qu'elle est passée
entre un élève et moi si le dimanche et
les domaines publics sont interdits de
chasse cécile dénonce une législation
compliqué un jour de trêve par semaine
serait une solution pour ces élèves
on serait plus en sécurité et puis enfin
je pense que juste un coup de feu ça
pourrait faire peur un cheval et qui
parle comme ça avec un cavalier
ce serait bien que vous êtes aussi pour
les gens qui veulent se balader en forêt
il pourrait se balader tranquillement
sanquer d'accident ni choses comme ça je
pense que ça peut être dangereux pour
les chevaux les bruits et tout ça même
pour le cavalier qui est sur le cheval
ça peut être dangereux
la fédération des chasseurs du cher
quant à elle compte bien continuer à
jouir du droit qu'elle paye pour chasser
7 jours sur 7
pourtant en france 150 accidents ont
lieu chaque année huit fois plus le
dimanche